okay thanks Alan for this introduction
and thanks to the organizers for
bringing me and us here so all this has
been over the years joint work with over
langara VA right there miserable and SEO
with their and Elizabeth cassia and
Dominic Bok dong who are far away
so this is about lossless compression or
over accountable alphabet so I make a
crash recall of lossless compression so
a lossless compression is just about
mapping messages that is sequence of
symbols from some alphabet and here we
will consider countable infinite
alphabets to code words that is sequence
of binary symbols 0 and 1 so as to
minimize the expected length of code
words in a one-to-one way and in an
unambiguous way so we assume that there
is a probability distribution over the
set of messages and the averages with
respect to this probability distribution
that's also called the source so asking
for in an unambiguous way that is we
want not only that there is just one
message for one code word but if you
want to concatenate code words make a
sequence of binary symbols it should
have a unique parsing into code words
and asking this just has consequences
and those consequences are summarized by
the craft mcmillan inequality that is if
you are using a non ambiguous code that
map's messages over binary sequences and
that assigns a length let me call lambda
to any code word f F of Omega then the
length of code words should satisfy this
inequality and this craft mcmillan
inequality this is a on if and only if
just provides a bridge between two words
the words of non ambiguous codes and the
words of probability distributions over
a set of messages that is any non
ambiguous codes defines possibly
defective probability distributions over
the set of messages
and conversely if you have a probability
distribution let's call it Q over the
set of messages it defines in an
ambiguous encoding where the code word
length is the so-called ideal code word
length this is it satisfies the almost
satisfies the Shannon lower upper bound
lower bound sorry that is it is the
binary logarithms of the probability of
the message up to one we can be fed to
another it medic coder to provide an
effective coding so equipped with that
we let me say well if you know the
source distribution then you're in a
good shape you have an optimal encoding
that can be further realized by of man
coding or feeling an arithmetic coder
but if you want a general-purpose
encoder then you have to choose a coding
probability which may not be and which
is in general not just the source
distribution okay and you have to pay
for that and the last you suffer this is
the expected difference between the code
words length and the ideal code word
length so minus log of P X N and plus
minus the log of the 0 minus the ideal
code word length we Swedes as a kullback
leibler the KL divergence between the
sampling probability the source
distribution and the coding distribution
then if you have a collections of
sources call it lambda over messages of
length n then you may call you may look
at the worst source distribution with
respect to your coding probability and
define the best coding probability or
look at what's the best coding
probability would give and this define
the minimax redundancy over messages of
length
and against your class lambda virtually
you may play another game you may put a
prior on on the sources soap i look at
the expected redundancy of your coding
strategy with respect to the random
source you've chosen look at the best
coding strategy and then look at the
least favorable prior and this define
the maximum redundancy and in this
setting the theorem from I think David
ostler show that the to coincide so you
have a strategy for getting lower bounds
by playing with priors and strategy for
getting upper bounds by cooking up nice
coating strategies ok so what is the
role of the alphabet size there what's
special with looking at countable others
well there are a host of clap classical
results for memoryless sources we finite
alphabet of cardinality k then almost
everything is known about the minimax
redundancy and a series of works going
from the 80's 90's tells us that then
the minimax redundancy over that class
of sources scales like this it scares
like the log of the message length and
in that way with respect to the size of
the alphabet and if you want more
precise results you have to look at
recent papers by much expand kofsky and
marcelo Weinberger but well we are not
looking at more precise results we want
more flexibility and another good news
about this finite alphabet setting that
we have plenty simple efficient
computationally and statistically
transparent coding strategy that
achieved those bounds
a crisp ski Trofimov strategy so this is
a mixture coding that takes advantage of
the conjugacy between dershlit priors
and binomial counts and multinomial
counts gives you something which is
asymptotically maxim in an approximately
minimax so it achieved that bounced up
to some constant and that gives you an
online coding strategy so it's only
based on counts so if you if this is a
number of occurrences of a symbol a in
your you have seen so far the the
posterior probability of seeing and
other a on the next symbol it's just
that expression and this is enough for
filling your arithmetic code so you're
in a very good shape as far as the
alphabet is finite size and you know
that the size of the alphabet you're
looking at countable alphabets well then
it's it's you get plenty of bad news so
in the early 90s Kieffer durfee poly
vandermolen got negative results so even
if you forget about any uniformity so if
you are looking at sources over the
integers and then whatever your well
there is this equivalence I said it if
you have a coding strategy that for any
source in your collection achieves
sublinear redundancy rate without any
uniformity there on on P then you can do
that if only if actually there your
collection of sources as a finite
bounded come back like your ages so you
need to put constraints on your
collection of sources if you want to
have non-trivial minimax redundancy and
okay so there are different ways of
getting out of this curse there's the
possibility of doing pattern coding that
was initiated by the San Diego group but
with a yawn Elizabeth we where we came
later and we worked on try to define
things that would be appealing to all
the way statisticians so we defined
envelope classes trying to put
constraints so as to enforce some kind
of compactness over the first class with
respect to the weak convergence so well
I put the definition there you we define
an envelope function just as a function
over the integers towards positive reals
so that the sum of the functions is
larger than 1 but it's still convergent
and the envelope class so the source
class is just defined by the first
marginal we're considering memorials
classes so it's okay and we just want
the probability of a symbol to be lot
smaller than f of X and actually this
provided FD k sufficiently fast this
defines tractable classes and the
richness of the class is actually well
captured by the so-called a blob
distribution so you pick some l and you
define it at the largest k such that the
sum of the FJ is larger than 1 so it
will define a probability over the large
integers and f of k is the probability
this distribution that we call the end
of distribution this is it the
distribution function though the tail
function or the survival functions will
be denoted by over line f and actually
we borrow a shorthand from extreme value
theory which is really underneath all
this investigation so U of T well
a short end for the quantile of order 1
minus 1 over T so T is something larger
than 1 love this envelope distributions
and actually they become the minimax
redundancy will be captured as a
functional of of you okay so what kind
of amp ups do we have in mind well they
well there are light tail envelopes and
a detail are drops so the light tail
envelopes will be defined as by taking a
smoothed version of the envelope
distribution and assuming that it has a
non decreasing other trait so this is
very much like the log concavity
question low concavity assumption that
was used yesterday afternoon and well
the Assad rate of a distribution is you
take the density it's the density
divided by the detail functions and we
assume it to be non decreasing so it's a
defined function that are say lighter
tales than geometric distributions the
geometric distribution just like I the
band at the boundary so for example you
can have an exponential geometric
envelopes or personal envelopes all they
fit in or you can have a discretized
versions of absolute values of Gaussian
they would fit in into this framework so
in the balance of extreme value fury
this is part of the google domain and
you are the what we call the regularly
varying envelopes or the mac stable
envelopes okay where you assume that the
tail functions or the tail quantize
functions are regularly varying with an
index gamma extreme value index that is
strictly positive means you have
something that looks very much like a
power law
okay and something slowly varying and
they behave in a quite different way so
to get intuitions about difficulty of
adaptive coding I will come to this in a
few minutes well let's get bound on
minimax redundancy for those envelope
classes so we start with an old results
with oh hell yeah so if you have a an
envelope class defined by its envelope
distribution in this way then you have
an upper bound which is often tight but
not completely tight that has a
following interpretation so at the
infimum over you where you put use
smaller than and the part of say the
tail functions and here you get an
expression that recalls the minimax
redundancy for coding over finite
alphabets this is a suggestions for a
coding strategy actually if the unlock
is known a good coding strategy consists
in choosing a threshold that is the
solutions of this equation approximate
solutions all the symbols that are
larger than the thresholds all the peaks
over thresholds will be encoded with a
general-purpose one-size-fits-all code
for example one of this alias code
school it's two times they or a little
bit more than the length of the binary
expansion of the symbol and all the
others will be encoded using a good crew
chef Smith traffic 360 trofimov mixtures
over alphabet of size the pretzel and if
the am tops is not known you need to
look for a data-driven threshold so I
just make an a party about the lower
bounds so for getting lower bounds on
minimax redundancy well there is a you
don't need really to go through finals
lemma you can use a redundancy capacity
firends that say that this lower bound
should be of the form of mutual
information
between the parameters something that
parameterize your sources and the
message for some by using game and
actually by playing on a duck tires that
are tailored to the to the AH blobs you
can check that there is a not so bad
bound that this lower bound is not less
than the expected number of distinct
symbols in a message which in turn can
be shown to be related to the solution
of this equation so which was given by
the ideals Frizzles but the bests lower
bounds are made in California and at
least with tools made in California so
for light tail envelopes and they are
this for so they were workout using by
Dominic Motown and Java decia myself
using previous work by general very
general work by David Oscar Manfred
upper front end 90s and you will see a
fashion because that shape so it looks
very much like what you get in the
finite alphabet setting but it extends
to the olden light light tale of herbs
for pomerleau envelopes our upper bounds
are lose and our lower bounds are not as
good at the upper bound that were
obtained by a san diego group recently
and a nice nice picture of this well
they've got very elegant proofs that for
paul weller envelopes their upper bound
as the same shape and the same order of
magnitude as our old trivial lower bound
okay so what are we doing with this
sort of have to go back
well sorry we don't know what the
envelope is and we don't want to assume
too much about where the envelope we
just want to put size constraints shape
constraints are on the envelopes so we
get two flavors of adaptivity an
activity is not really a bad word in
data compression unfortunately so we try
to tell her what God from what we got
from HR statistics so there is a natural
notion so we would like a coding
strategy that given a collections of
envelopes of source classes does almost
as well as the best at the taylormade
coding strategy so this one would be
adapted to this source class this one
would be twice universe this is feasible
for light tail envelopes for the
collection of lighting envelopes but for
massive envelope class for max table or
regularly regularly varying envelope
classes we don't know so we are happy to
use this downsized notion of adaptivity
say weekly adaptive we allow slackness
of order loving log so what are the
coding codes the coding strategy that
achieve that are really simple they all
based on fresh holding and censoring so
you take your and progressive censoring
so for the light a lamp lopes the
strategy is really easy you look at the
largest symbols in so far to the last
record and if the next symbol is larger
than this then you will censor it you
will press all it so escape it by zero
and code it using a general-purpose
coder and using the last symbol there
and put the good symbols you use it
Khrushchev ski trofimov encoding for
that so I skip
a little bit the examples and tell what
we get then this very simple
computationally effective and concept of
this simple strategy is actually
completely adaptive the minimax
redundancy rate for those light their
envelopes is actually as this simple
nice form and this is achieved by this
auto center encode provided the envelope
is you attack the non decreasing uttered
rates and if you want envelope with
heavier tails then you have to threshold
in a different way because if you were
using this simple resolving strategy the
effective alphabet you're using would
expand far too fast then you you would
have a linear redundancy which is
exactly what you don't want so you have
to to think that the thresholds you
should look at should be solutions of
these equations or it would be the same
solution of this equation and the
solutions actually would capture the
regular varying properties of your
envelope and you could craft an
empirical threshold the data-driven
threshold that will really mimic the
behavior of this ideal threshold without
being told about it and then using that
huh you would achieve this well still
frustrating results we get activity
because well the minimax redundancy is
not less than this strange results
French ideal threshold and the
redundancy of this our censoring code is
not more than a constant number of this
quantity that goes like that grows like
a power of n Times log n whereas the
minimax redundancy as shown by the San
Diego
as this order of magnitude which is up
to a constant of this order so we are
off by a factor of Logan and I think I
should slap here now
busted relation between your notion of
activity and Lysander brutality yes I
think it's the same notion there did and
we went through the literature and so
this adaptivity as it is known in you
know nonparametric statistics so flying
from the Russian school didn't really
catch up in this field of lossless
compression so there's this twice
universal coding or Iraq achill
University a universality sorry at least
there are several words and several
works on the several perspective but
well this is this has not been
mainstreaming in lossless compression as
far as i understand it so the
frustration here is we don't know
whether still whether there's a price to
pay for universality so if you want
analogies with a extreme value theory
estimating this game a parameter you
have to pay a price for universality if
you don't know the so-called
second-order properties this crisis
sells less than than a log in but for
this problem I I don't know if there is
a reduction between estimating gamma do
we need to estimate gamma to be to be
efficient or not or is there a weakness
in our analyzes there's no open problems
and this is one of them
or is it just regular very functional
well underneath there is a for the nuts
and bolts they're actually an interplay
between concept from extreme value
theory and concentration of measure
arguments I think the nice thing is that
for light rail envelopes this maximum
symbol the recourse well they are they
fit into this concentration on two
values phenomenon that shows up in
community oryx from time to time this
this is because we have is
non-decreasing as out rate so basically
the maximum is your more than geometric
it's either some function of N or this
function plus one ok yeah I think that
that all comes from from the same day
moods paper by Clive Anderson from 1970s
and on the other side the football
general-purpose on top so every tale
unlocks the threshold to this empirical
analog of this small MN at the shape of
well it's very nice to analyze it
because it's it behaves like a personal
random variables so it has all the
desirable concentration properties we
would like to have so there this makes
the analyzes less gory